marcel jullian bonsoir toi tu publié aux
éditions rmc c'est un livre qui
s'appelle loin de massilia
alors est ce que tu peux même le résumer
en deux minutes je vais essayer de le
faire rapidement oui c'est un roman de
commandes normalement qui m'a été
inspiré j'avais envie de parler de
marseille qui était la ville de mon
enfance et de mes vacances j'ai des
cannes est un personnage appelé marc
odieux de marcel qui est arrivé des
choses qui ne me sont pas arrivés
j'aurais peut-être souhaité qu'elle
n'arrive à ses suppôts scié et sa part
de l'âme de l'attentât qui a eu lieu en
1934 contre le
le roi de raison de premiers google
d'avis et se termine par la destruction
du vieux port de marseille dans 43 par
les événements et c'est confondre est
comment dire qu'on a une belle métisse
sensuelle passionnante et à quatre mois
que par l'amour qu'on a pour une petite
ville marcel marseille parlons des films
en noir et blanc
le marseille de pépé le moko elle
marseille quand les camps les
différentes des puces s'est mêlé le
moment où le l'exotisme éviter d'avoir
de la sottise moment où vous vraiment
c'était parfumé et insolent et super
alors pourquoi quelqu'un comme toi qui
quand même à des possibilités d'édition
d'ultimes j'en suis sûr edit ça chez rmc
dit si on reste que c'est une affaire
d'amitié comme l'invité pour marseille
c'est un
en garçons ça va être ouverte un taux
qui était non pas de résister ou chez
plon quand j'en étais président et qui
vit riches ça et qui m'a dit est ce que
tu me vends un jour un livre j'ai dit
tiens je vais faire ce cri d'amour à
marseille je n'ai pas peur que le
critique littéraire soit un peu rebuté
par le par le sigle rmc édition sur les
pas été mieux chez gallimard chez
grasset chaque jour suffit sa peine
mignon je pense que la prévision qui
n'avaient causé will daniels et des
années de préparation ce qui a été là
tout simplement une distraction du coeur
a été agréable je trouve que c'était une
distraction du coeur donné à l'horizon
d'amitié qui s'aligne sur son la
marseillaise cependant pas que j'étais
partout et je suis revenue lorsqu'on m'a
fait bien sûr 14 détails que telle rue
avait-elle pas telle autre et et et
c'est là que j'ai vu ce que cet exemple
parce que les seniors sont ce qu'ils
sont et et les îles sont exactes
ce sont les appellations va pas on sait
qu'on pedro gagné 1 autrement puisque on
a dans cupola le souvenir et le
marseille d'aujourd'hui qui est quand
même rudement islamisée
est-ce que 7,7 choc depuis retrouvé ce
marseille un peu pagnolesque de ton
enfance est aujourd'hui de voir des rues
entières ou à l'heure de la prière des
gens sont à genoux en direction de la
mecque c'est à dire tous à cohabiter et
maintenant tout à ce segment ce et ceux
qui menacent je crois est un signe des
temps est devenue absurde ce qui faisait
la différence et était un enrichissement
est devenue une erreur de quotas et à
partir de ce moment-là tout et tout bien
bête et je le regrette parce que
vraiment la notion quant à un homme de
mon âge on lui de la mission racine en
même temps dans une notion serions crir
de conneries sont nés après moi je et
avec une sécurité adt et sans aller
chercher ma tante grande veste elle
travaille au petit provençal et la nuit
aller la chercher quand elle travaillait
a traversé toutes les rues chaudes où
les pubs de marseille était était ma
protection et rencontrer un
anwar al arab un ton kg ha était une
chance est absolument pas un danger on
est absurde c'est exotique mais puis
c'était que les gens avaient peur de
rien et avec nous est toute fraîche pas
durer car même si j'aimais route était
prenable c'est pour toi c'est pour
plonger à tuer sur tf1
oui je suis pas sûr de suivre à vue puis
il fut va commander j'étais sûr je serai
à l'écran je suis à je suis conseiller
cas ça se passe comment ça se voit non
pas très souvent mais chaque fois qu'il
ya une question un petit peu essentiel
ou par une note devant un coup de fil
c'est simple mais combien de gens comme
toi là qui sont des conseillers spéciaux
du président bien ceux qui le sont et ce
qu'ils ont été nommés
il ya ceux qui le croient j'ai beaucoup
de monde ouais alors là tu es sur l'a5
d'un bain de minuit on essaie de
recevoir on pense qu'à cette heure-là il
ait plus de guerre des chaînes donc on a
reçue du compte que c'est un bel
optimisme nous refusons les yeux dans
les yeux une guerre on est ravi que soit
l'intérêt que patrick toth d'ardents
viendra que qui vous viendra mais il ya
un an il ya quand même une anecdote qui
je trouve est un petit peu choquant
c'est le fait que drucker n'ai pas pu
parler de son livre sur la vie sauve sa
triste
effectivement la triste parce que j'aime
bien michel tricot casque vous aime les
gens avec qui je travaille et que je
trouve que je pense que pour moi
politique d'abord disait quelqu'un qui
se connaissent et que j'ai connu deux
minutes vous admirez politique d'abord
ça veut dire que si la règle du jeu
avait été convenable et été édictée si
les français connaissaient une charte
bien mieux visuelle simple je crois qu
on ne serait pas obligé de ce mal
conduit je trouve que ce sont les
politiques qui ne faut jamais obliger
les gens à devenir féroce et être
contraint est offert aux poursuivi j'ai
trop vécu l'une télévision d'état où je
me rendais compte que l'argent de la
redevance qui tenait une espèce de
sérénité pour ne pas comprendre combien
les gens qui vont chercher cet argent
par la publicité et qui peuvent avoir
peur pour leurs sous comme dirait mon
père au lieu de d'abord soccer pour les
sous du contribuable qui est quand même
beaucoup pour moi frissonnons sont
obligés de se battre comme des chiens et
si la règle du jeu avait été convenable
et juste été contraint à être comptable
et je crois qu'ils auraient été plus
heureux de ça je crois qu'il est très
difficile à remonter faut des actions
vin connaît quand est vendu à à
quelqu'un qui appartenait à tout le
monde finalement qu'est-ce qui a même
sur leur vision mais jeudi il faut le
problème d'abord fait cette tentation de
je crois qu'il faut très vite remonter
aux trois chaînes une puis deux puis
trois bâtiments où il y en avait 3 et
qui si elle avait été toute étroits
d'état on aurait stagné dans le match
avait reconnu une raison de il aurait
fallu forer qui vivrait beaucoup plus il
suffisait dans lesquelles est une peau
collègues pourquoi pas les deux pourquoi
pas la 3d devient l'autre mais je pense
que si la règle du jeu avait été établie
on n'aurait pas ce sentiment aussi
détestable que celui qu'on a aujourd'hui
à là je dis que tant les règles du jeu
contraignent les ans avec moins bien que
même si l'ensemble de la cgt des hommes
qui y perd les gens de beaucoup comme
les baffles
c'est vrai que tu fais des imitations
montré peu dont il ya eu mieux que ça
malheureusement pas malheureusement les
paris supportable parce que moi j'ai
fait une émission on en demande une
jambe le jeune hacker surveilleront la
vérité non j'ai eu quelques poids dans
des méchancetés limitée du bassin très
compliqué
vous que malraux eu le temps de voler
tellement tout une opération que mes
pattes histoire mais c'est vrai que cela
tu assumes accueilli ce qui peut le
faire oui c'est peut-être pas
souhaitable comme je ne peux pas chanter
comme n'est pas totalement société mon
imitation de malraux mme parlant de
devaux lui parlant d'autres personnes si
bon mais seulement de leurs 2 et voilà
je suis mal coiffé surface allemande
elle parlera de nous prêter mon fils du
pasteur pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu